a deleted final showdown for black widow
and more red guardian taskmaster and
elena moments were all cut from the
final version of the movie
yipikai ruby lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing all the deleted
scenes from black widow a post-credits
moment that teased natasha's return from
the dead plus the avenger cameo you
never got to see
spoilers ahead of course so take care
the black widow post-credits scene sees
elena visit natasha's tombstone in ohio
and as she mourns her sister she
whistles softly
this is the same whistle that the
sisters used to call each other as
children and which they also did as they
parted at the end of the movie
in the end credits scene after elena
whistles as a brief
pause as she waits or hopes for a
response as do we but there isn't one
however black widow director kate
shortland has now revealed in an
interview with variety that there were
discussions about including a whistle
reply in the scene
natasha of course died in end game when
she gave her life in return for the soul
stone and together with tony stark she's
one of the few avengers that have so far
remained dead in the mcu
if elena had heard a reply to her
whistle even if it seemed like it wasn't
real and she'd imagined it then i expect
it would have fueled lots of speculation
that natasha could soon return in an
upcoming mcu project
similar to some fans wishful hoping
about iron man's hammer sound at the end
of end game
many other dead marvel characters have
already made a return to the mcu
including vision and loki albeit in
different versions and timelines and
even carlson was reanimated for agents
of shield
after loki killed him in the avengers so
i wouldn't be totally opposed to the og
black widow returning if it was done in
the right way
after all we don't know exactly what
happens to a character when they go to
the mcu version of the soul world and
whether there's any way they could be
retrieved
thanos saw and spoke to a young version
of dead gamora after he snapped
a hint that the soul world could be
accessible perhaps of course there'd be
many fans who'd love for natasha to
return in a black widow sequel or even a
different movie and i think that
including the whistle response would
have given fans the impression that
marvel was committed to doing that
in some way which is my guess for why
they ultimately didn't do it
leave a thumbs up if you wish there'd
been a whistle response and let me know
whether you think natasha should come
back from the dead
the main events of the movie culminate
with team natasha taking out drakov
liberating his brainwashed widows and
crashing the airborne red room to the
ground
as secretary ross together with a large
military convoy heads towards the crash
site
nat sends her adoptive family and the
red room survivors away while she waits
to face
the music alone what exactly happens
next is left to our imagination as the
film cuts to black
before returning with an epilogue scene
set two weeks later that shows natasha
is still free
footage from the black widow trailers
however indicates that originally there
was an
alternate or extended version of this
ending where ross gets out to survey the
scene together with a swat team from the
beginning of the movie
you can see from the hungarian writing
on the truck behind ross that the red
room appeared to crash down somewhere in
hungary perhaps
even near budapest there's also deleted
footage in the trailers of armed
marksmen emerging from cars and scores
of military personnel taking up
positions among the wreckage of the red
room
with their sights presumably set on
natasha it seems like this would have
been an almost impossible situation for
natasha to escape from by herself
although given some of the crazy fun
action in the movie it's not
unfeasible to think that she would have
found a way out given she and hawkeye
survived a shootout with the hungarian
special forces
many years earlier it's also possible
that she somehow struck a deal with ross
or tricked him again in some way though
i don't think he'd be especially
amenable to a negotiation
there were some great moments with david
harbour's red guardian while he's locked
up in the russian prison and we find him
bragging about the supposed battles he
had with captain america
what year was this lady 384
captain america was still frozen in ice
then and the prison break scene when
natasha and elena come to rescue him
originally included more extensive red
guardian combat scenes
the marketing material shown fighting
other prisoners who got
out after a prison riot kicked off and
in some behind-the-scenes footage we can
also see alexi
fighting off a pack of prison guards
whereas in the final version red
guardian's only encounter with a guard
is while he's climbing at one of the
walls
i suspect the longer prison fight was
cut for time given the final movie was
already two and a quarter hours long
though personally i never felt the film
dragged some more red guardian moments
from the trailers that didn't make it
into the final movie include alexi
flexing and admiring his muscles in
molina's bathroom which is deleted from
the scene where he decides to put on his
old red guardian
suit we also don't get to see him
putting on his helmet as he does here in
the promos
and alexi's reaction after he leaves the
bathroom with his costume on
is noticeably different in the trailer
compared to the final movie
still fits
it still fits speaking to inverse
director kate shortland said that there
was a good deal of improvisation on set
especially during the dinner table
reunion and i found some more dialogue
by alexi for that scene in the trailers
that wasn't used in the final film
you got fat smelly water
in the final version of the movie this
is how that exchange goes instead
you got fat but still good i just got
out of the prison i
uh i have a lot of energy oh please
don't do that
also in the trailers but not in the
final film is footage of taskmaster
watching black widow fight and analyzing
her moves
it's called science taskmaster and that
line from elena did not make it into the
final film either
by the way the footage from that
cutscene is actually taken from
natasha's hallway fight in iron man 2.
in the final movie taskmaster analyzes
natasha's moves during the fight on the
bridge
rather than in advance and instead we
see the antagonist studying a hawkeye
fight scene which sets up the taskmaster
arrow attack on nat and elena in
budapest
there's also a small piece of dialogue
that drakov appears to say to taskmaster
in the trailers that wasn't in the final
film
this appears to imply that originally
part of taskmaster's mission was to
capture natasha or elena and take her to
the red room
rather than just retrieve the antidote
vials which was her main mission in the
finished film
the story of who was underneath the mask
and how she was part of natasha's red
ledger fitted well with the overall
theme of the movie about the abuse of
girls and women
however i think the movie's promotional
material led many fans to believe that
taskmaster was going to be a much
bigger villain for example the way one
trailer was cut even implied that
taskmaster was going to be the big bad
rather than drakov his call signs
taskmaster
he controls the red room i really
enjoyed the film however the marketing
may well have set the wrong expectations
for fans going into the movie when it
came to taskmaster's role
natasha and elena also had some deleted
and alternate versions of their scenes
in budapest
after their fight in the apartment this
quip from natasha was cut from the final
movie
it's good to see you too sis and then
there's a line from elena that appeared
in a lot of the promos for the film
natasha my sister after all this time
what brings you home i can see why this
was cut as it doesn't make a lot of
sense in the movie given it was elena
who sent natasha the vials of antidote
together with their childhood photo in
the first place so elena already knew
why natasha had come home
and there's also a deleted line from
elena's dialogue about what she imagined
natasha's life would have been like in
america
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
we did get to briefly see some of the
red room widows training in unison
after team natasha arrived on the
floating platform
however as you might expect for any big
film like this
and as we can see from the trailers a
lot more footage was shot at the widow's
training choreography that didn't make
it into the final cut
and a cameo by tony stark was also
apparently on the cards according to a
september 2019 deadline report from the
saturn awards where it was stated that
quote
downey will be seen in the role of stark
one more time in the marvel prequel
black widow
clearly tony stark wasn't in the movie
although elena did mention him at one
point as one of natasha's avenger
scientist friends who she thought could
help analyze the mind control antidote
formula why don't you take it to one of
your super scientist friends
tony stark maybe given their final words
in civil war though
i doubt they'd have been on speaking
terms during the main events of black
widow
so i don't think it would have made a
lot of sense for him to appear in the
film
t'challa told ross what you did so
they're coming for you i'm not the one
that needs to watch their back
still possible scenarios where he might
have fit would have been via a flashback
or reusing footage from a previous movie
like when thor ragnarok used an age of
ultron cliff of natasha to calm the hulk
and bring banner back
alternately tony could have been a voice
over the phone similar to how hawkeye's
voice
was in the movie during the flashback to
the assassination attempt on drakov
we need confirmation takeoffs in the
building since recording this video kate
shortland has revealed in an interview
with gamesradar that initially there
were discussions about whether any of
the other avengers or existing marvel
characters should be involved in the
movie but in the end both she and kevin
feige agreed that quote
she doesn't need the boys we didn't want
it to feel like she needs the support we
want her to stand alone and she does
and if you want to see all the black
widow connections to the mcu which did
make it into the final movie things you
missed in the post-credits scenes and
the secret link between bucky and the
red room tap here to watch my black
widow
mcu changes video or follow the link in
the video description
so do you wish any of these deleted
scenes have been in the final movie and
do you think we'll ever see black widow
again
on screen comment with your thoughts
below and if you enjoyed this then do
like
and share the video i really appreciate
him you can tap left for my full black
widow breakdown
or tap right for another video you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee guy movie lovers